so here's the thing about storytelling
this term is used and abused in so many
ways um to the point that it's actually
detering people right now because it
sounds like
fluff but to me storytelling is all
about engagement at the end of the day
whether you're coming into an investor
meeting or a client meeting what we need
to remember is that we have an audience
in front of us and we need to bring
relevancy into the conversation and the
best way and it's scientifically proven
to connect with the person in front of
you is to wrap that information to wrap
that relevancy in your pitch in the form
of story now where most people get it
wrong is that they're trying to sell
stories and my Approach is don't sell
stories tell stories and allow your
story to do the selling for
[Music]
you miam well welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
all the way from New York right uh from
New Jersey just across the river uh but
yeah I appreciate it love love being
here with you and it's good seeing you
again fantastic to see you as well H we
met last time in a webinar that you
hosted talking about resiliency and
impact of uh of the war um and it was
with phenomenal Partners I was onon our
to part and and I really appreciate you
taking the time now to join me and
telling a little bit about the story of
M alayam and telling you know your the
problems that that you're seeing and the
opportunities you're seeing in in
working with entrepreneurs and Founders
and and really taking the amazing work
that they're doing but telling it in a
way that that is understood is
compelling and makes sense for also
investors so I'm looking forward to
diving deep into it um right before we
get started into all of that mul tell me
a little bit about yourself you know as
a person a bit about your background and
then we'll dive into problems space
absolutely so you throughout my career I
was involved with tech companies and
managing various marketing teams in the
capacity of VPO marketing CMO let us
teams from premium sales all the way to
unicornism in in some point and what I
realized very early on in startups is
that content and storytelling is key
because at the end of the day you're
coming in with a ground breaking product
a groundbreaking team a lot of
innovative uh work that is going into
Uncharted territories and in every
aspect of the work you really have to
sell your vision whether it is to get
the investors on board or the first
clients on board um and that is what
really drew me to the world of tech and
after 10 years of leading different
marketing teams I've decided to launch
my agency Atlantic brands and Atlantic
Brands is focused on helping emerging
companies emerging founders with
investor pit in helping helping them
that sorry helping them fine-tune their
storyline their pitch the way they
deliver their Vision into investors um
and the other part of that agency is
fractional CMO services but today we're
going to focus on the storytelling
part phenomenal I love it for you
storytelling public speaking and um what
what what does that mean to you so
here's the thing about storytelling this
term is used and abused in so many ways
um to the point that it's actually
deterring people right now because it
sounds like
fluff but to me storytelling is all
about engagement at the end of the day
whether you're coming into an investor
meeting or a client meeting what we need
to remember is that we have an audience
in front of us and we need to to bring
relevancy into the conversation and the
best way and it's scientifically proven
to connect with the person in front of
you is to wrap that information to wrap
that relevancy in your pitch in the form
of story now where most people get it
wrong is that they're trying to sell
stories and my Approach is don't sell
stories tell stories and allow your
story to do the selling for you so
storytelling is all about connection
connecting and engaging with the person
in front of
you MH and so the what is the challenge
of of actually doing that from on now
specifically on a Founder perspective
what what is the challenge of getting
the story and then telling it right well
it's all about understanding context
right A lot of times I see brilon
founders with developed Brilliant
Solutions brilliant Tech Solutions were
coming in and they following themselves
on the understanding that pitching the
product pitching the
technology is what is going to sell the
business at the end of it but the
challenge is is that's not what
investors are looking for in in early
stage companies they really are looking
for for the first connection with the
founder to see that we have one investor
founder fit two that we have found their
Market fit and to that we have investor
Market fit now the ability to connect
all of those points in the Triangle of
fit in fundraising you can only do by
really engaging the investor in front of
you to understand your purpose if they
don't understand your purpose if they
cannot connect to you your technology
your Market size and your traction are
irrelevant because those are secondary
if they don't have the ability to fully
understand why and what it is that
you're doing and this is where
storytelling comes into
play I completely get that and I think
the natural question stems you know
Founders spend all their time day in day
out nighttime dreaming about their their
fit how necessary they are how
passionate they are this is their you
know you would expect the founders and
entrepreneurs to be the best in the
world at telling their story so why is
it that when it comes to the to the
Moment of Truth sometimes they may not
do it as well as they
could the answer to that is very simple
and it is focus as a founder and you
know it as a Founder who raised
successfully and congratulation on that
again the answer to that is focus there
are so many things that are going into
the Founder's head the opportunities the
risk the need to raise money and all of
those weights that are bearing on their
shoulders are forcing them to drive a
lot of information into the presentation
rather than understanding in very simple
terms what it is that we do and what it
is that we do best and when you have the
ability to focus on that you can craft
your story line to build up to the
inflection point of this is why gr
aesome and by adding too many layers
feature dumping yourself your product
onto an investor you're diluting your
value proposition so rule number one and
I like to call it the rule of one in
pitching is that you have one audience
one problem one solution keep that in
mind because investors at the end of the
day are ordinary people like you and me
they don't have the ability to process
gazillions of pieces of information they
want the information to be simple enough
so they'll be able to go and sell it
back to their Partners so keep your pach
Focus that's the biggest challenge that
I see that is killing Founders today in
their
peit amazing so where where do you fit
into this so H before we talk about how
you work with Founders and entrepreneurs
and what your what what you do how how
did you decide that this is what you
want to be doing with your skills why
why why this problem for you and wh why
why are you the right person here so
it's it's quite a fascinating story um I
was always drawn to public speaking
itching standing in front of the the
crowd I got my masters from Colombia
University in strategic Communications I
stayed to teach their public speaking
after my
graduation and one day while I was a CMO
at at
co-pilot a person from my network
reached out and said listen miti
something is changing in the market the
way we pit is no longer working I'm not
able to penetrate the the threshold it's
just there is something happening in the
market those were the early signs of
2023 and the tech Market going down and
what I've noticed is that that founder
like many many Founders in those days
and until today actually follow the
traditional pitch deck template and I
said okay if 500 people are pitching the
same we need to approach this
differently we need to approach pitching
not from a product and a selling
perspective but from an engagement
perspective you have an audience in
front of you so the step the first step
you need to understand is that you have
to connect to the audience if you're not
connecting to the audience your message
is not going to go true and then and the
best way to do it is with a story and
then you have to build the layers of the
pitch on top of that so by helping that
founder raise $4.5 million with nothing
but a presentation with nothing but a
piece of paper in their hand they were
pre-product pre-revenue
actually that really got me hooked on
this niche of investor pitching and I
started doing it with one then the
second one came and the third to the
point that I decided to launch the
agency as a full-time thing so tell me
about the first one how or the or one of
the very first ones so what what was
sort of the the the real experience you
had which at the end of it you said wow
you know this is a real problem and and
I'm pretty good at this I can actually
get results and this is something that I
want to now scale and do more yeah so I
remember the first founder came to my
house we sat on the sofa and she said
I'm I'm I'm really shy I don't know if I
can Peach this the first time peaching
and she was a senior executive in in
previous companies and led those
companies to massive growth and the
first thing we try to understand is what
was your
inspiration you found in this company
and she told me her inspiration and she
told me how she lived through that pain
and I said well what we have to do first
is make you relieve that pain through
your investor because once the investor
realize that you live through the pain
that you're pitching that taks a green
light in their hand they know you have
what it takes to drive this home and I
remember
she called me she went to Israel to meet
with an
investor and she said M we met for
coffee and the investment is
in and I said that's phenomenal that's
actually better than I ever
anticipated um but the idea is that
whatever inspired
you to start your company it is more
likely it's most likely to inspire an
investor to invest in you and when
you're able to tap into it that is key
now the second understanding is that I
found with starting from the very first
companies I started working with is that
sometimes in order to get the business
you don't have to talk business meaning
you have to achieve the connection first
a lot of time I see funders coming in
with 300 billion TS unbelievable Excel
sheets that are also so documented but
Excel sheets don't sell vision you have
to sell your vision
first amazing so that this leads me to
it to you asking so what are the common
pitfalls you you just mentioned one that
you see Founders make when crafting
their stories that you're looking at
them and saying okay everybody this is
great but you're missing you know these
huge important distilment which will
which will hinder your objectives here
so you mentioned you already touched on
one of them which I think is important
to double down on is is out you know how
do you actually get them to buy into the
vision not just the large Tam which
every pitch deck should have
obviously well I actually disagree with
it I think the time should not be in a
pach deck um and but we'll touch on the
time for a second the first thing is
that and especially in emerging
companies we have to understand that
invest by the way we didn't we didn't
have a we didn't have a number on our
time on ours so see exactly and part of
the the reason you probably are a smart
founder was able to Su to successfully
raise in today's market so one look we
have to understand that investor invest
in Founders first you can break away
from it you have to accept that this is
what they're looking for once you
establish that you need to focus your
first three minutes of the presentation
on your story let them connect to you
because that's what they're looking for
then layer the presentation on that and
where I see most Founders make the
mistake is the drive to the business
opportunity the business opportunity is
worthless without the right founder and
investors are no longer dazzled by 300
billion Tams now let's speak about it
very openly when it comes to Tam there
is not a single company in the western
world that was able to achieve Tam not
Google not not Facebook not Apple not
Microsoft no one you know why because
when you achieve time it means you're a
monopoly so one thing that I strongly
recommend companies to do is come in
with realistic projections of the sales
that you can generate and the road map
and the journey make sure that you're
are
grounded
two after you've done your story right
know your numbers right story will get
you the the connection numbers will get
you the validation and this is where a
lot of Founders are falling so once you
got the investor hooked on you now you
need to show them that you really know
the numbers don't just Google Tam some s
numbers and come up with rough
guesstimates
build your goto Market in relation to
the story that you created meaning if
I'm going after a certain business how
many how many of those do I have in the
US market and how many of those do I
realistically know I can get in the next
two
years there is no shame in saying we're
not going to achieve one billion or $100
million in Revenue in two years no one
is expecting you to do it in two years
keep it grounded and
lastly
know
exactly why you have the unfair
advantage and that is where we spoke
about Focus come in and understand what
it is that makes you better in position
to achieve those sales it can be
gazillion reasons it has to be one that
is elevating you above everyone else
your product may have many features but
there is one reason why you are better
than everyone else so don't try to make
a burrito uh sorry a buffet or a burrito
list of items by which you are a good
investment just go for the focused
long interesting so help help me
translate these these um ideas into more
behaviors or attributes that then an
investor would experience from a Founder
for example when I hear you talk about
know your numbers I I hear about you
know I hear this attribute of of
groundedness and rigor that you know it
doesn't even matter necessarily what the
numbers are it's the fact that there is
trust that this is a Founder that is not
just here to sell me on something but
they've done their work and that they
they believe in the research they've
done and they're rigorous about it
exactly that's that's a really good
point so if we're going to the numbers
right and and again I see it all the
time with Founders have a need to speak
about a billion dollar market and a
billion dollar market okay everyone is
talking about a billion dollar market we
we wouldn't be here if if we didn't
think that we can make this company a
billion dollar company that's the entire
purpose of investing right we want to
grow to unicorn status but I'll give you
an example that illustrates it and how
you can keep it grounded um I was able
to raise money for carbine one of the
companies I worked on based on a dinner
that I had with a really high Network
individual and I explained to in very
simple term look our solution is
designed for 911 centers in the us there
are 8,911 centers in the US at $100 per
seat per month at average of 12 seats
per Center this is how much we can we
think we can make in year one two or
three so now there is logic behind the
numbers don't use numbers to Dazzle this
is where I go back to what I said before
don't sell
stories be very very grounded in your
pitch it's a quality that many founders
are shining away from being grounded
they want to sell the big Vision the big
dream no sell
reality right and it's almost like
you're not just selling real I mean the
reality need assuming that the reality
leads to a good business proposition
right that is sort of table Stakes but
and and ideally those are that's a
logical process that every that
everybody will say any sound investor
who understands this Market will say
yeah that's that that makes sense now
it's a question of sell them on your
logic sell them on your process right
sell them on your
rigger exactly and and they love to see
your rigger they love to see your hustle
they're looking for it they love to see
your grind and what we also need to
understand is that look the purpose of
the first peit you're not going to get
money yeah your P you're not going to
get money in that meeting you need to
understand that the purpose of the first
peit is one to connect to the investor
but you also need to remember that that
investor now needs to go and tell your
story with conviction to his or her
partners and they need to make a
decision together if they're going to
invest in your company yeah when they
pitch you they have to come up with
grounded numbers everything has to
connect from the vision to the numbers
to the ask if the numbers are not
matching the vision if the ask is not
matching the numbers if the numberb are
not
grounded the investor is not going to
cut through the threshold of his or her
Partners now you're not positioning
yourself for Success if you're going for
the dream sell the vision and make the
vision a
reality phenomenal um I and I think that
there's there's more I mean I'm sure we
can take many of the pieces of advice
that you're giving entrepreneurs in
different modalities we just here
touched on in on on the context of
numbers and research but I'm sure that
there is also ways in which information
is even presented vocally in in the way
that you're that you're experiencing the
person on a human level that then
translates down to more basic
fundamental traits of a person that they
would want to work with and so H I'm
sure that there's many many things we
can we can come up with so many and and
by the way I'll just share it here um
all of my methods of investor pitching
and public speaking and engagement is
available online I share that data for
free so if you go to medium and you look
for Mel and you look for my name if you
go on LinkedIn you can see all of my
principles on how to successfully peit
but you you know going to the small
details of your tone and how to Peach
it's actually amazing sometimes to see
brilliant Founders like really brilliant
people they standing in front of an
investor and they look at the
slide yeah and it happens and all of
those things needs to be factored so but
I said different thing I think the core
of investor pitching is to understand
one thing first you have to
connect then you have to present the
opportunity the business argument as in
context to the story you presented at
the beginning it's not a linear process
where you go by problem solution
traction demo everything has to be
layered together in order to create the
right
context I love it m thank you so much
for coming and thank you for sharing
nuggets of your experience and and uh
obviously so you know the medium and
Link in um you know you have all the
tools there but I think that there it
does it they get you to a certain level
and obviously the the personal
engagement then takes to a to a
different level so thank you again for
being here excited to share this with
everybody thank you thank you Michael
thank you for having me
[Music]